as Bobby living up to the hype or is it
destined for the bargain been at Walmart
the critic's verdict is already in okay
then audiences have been fascinated with
director Greta goig's taken Barbie since
the first teaser debuted late last year
from its star-studded Castle it's a
resting in very big visuals Barbie has
become a source of cultural phenomenon
even before his release thanks in part
to its viral marketing campaign recent
weeks have also seen the rise of
barberheimer your friendly sort of
rivalry the film has with Christopher
Nolan's Oppenheimer both projects are
set to debut on the same day for girl
work it was important to inspect the
mythology of Barbie for more angles
giving audiences a nuanced and
self-aware take on the iconic doll the
director told USA Today one thing we
really wanted to do was look at this
complicated icon from all angles but
always approach everything with a big
heart fans around the world are clearly
interested in gerwig's irreverent take
on the doll with early tracking from
variety suggesting that the Warner
Brothers film could debut to over 100
million dollars domestically luckily
audiences won't be showing up to their
Barbie blowout parties to watch a dirt
as the film is receiving extremely
positive reviews across the board lubric
Dominic Griffin had nothing but positive
things to say about the film writing
it's a genre blending tonally audacious
film that wrestled to the patriarchy and
capitalism under the guise of a movie
Indie wire critic Kate herbland was
equally enthusiastic about Greta
gerbig's film saying Barbie is a
lovingly crafted Blockbuster with a lot
on his mind the kind of feature that was
surely benefit from repeat viewings if
reviews are anything to go by Warner
Brothers Discovery might just have the
biggest hits of the summer on his hands
while Barbie is set to open big thanks
in part to Stellar pre-sales these
positive reviews confirm that the film
is more than just hype and while the
trailers show Barbie as a delightful
summer ROM perfect for the family many
critics are surprised by how existential
the film is do you guys ever think about
dying
slash film writer BJ Colangelo has
boldly labeled Barbie one of the best
films of the Year particularly praising
director Greta Gerwig for asking big
questions Colangelo wrote in a 9 out of
10 review Greta Gerwig did The
Impossible with Bobby marrying both a
confetti bright sensibilities of the
plastic toy that has been a vital friend
to many for over half a century and a
sharp screenplay that inspires
existential ruminations on gender
politics and self-love Insider critic
Kirsten Acuna was also equally
enthusiastic about goex epic comparing
it to a live-action Toy Story she wrote
Barbie is fun to watch sending viewers
on an emotional roller coaster as it
delivers pure joy one moment before
serving up Nostalgia at the next Acuna
also pointed out how existential and
impactful the film is writing
emotionally Barbie grapples with the
purpose of her existence and what to do
if she's not making the world a better
place and is instead causing girls to
internalize and realistic beauty
standards while many praise Barbie for
investigating the character's Legacy
some critics weren't super impressed by
the film's choices time film critics
Stephanie zakarik said Barbie probably
is a feminist movie but only in the most
scatter shot way luckily it seems like
most critics can't agree on one thing
the film's powerful performances as of
the making of this video Barbie boasts a
89 score on Rotten Tomatoes well that
number will likely change one thing
won't the love critics have for Margot
Robbie the Australian actor is receiving
Universal Acclaim for her turn as the
iconic doll IGN writer Alyssa Morris
says Robbie was born to play the
character writing there's no doubt that
Robbie deserves award attention for the
awe-inspiring balancing actually Nails
as a film's veneer of Salinas peels back
to reveal something much deeper the rap
writer Thomas lovely particularly called
out the facial expressions Robbie and
Gosling adopted to appear as convincing
humanoid dolls saying it can't be
overstated how far both Robbie and
Gosling push their facial muscles and
star power to charge their respective
dolls real world Awakening in ways both
laugh out loud funny and heartbreaking
Robbie isn't the only one receiving
Applause for her role with many writers
like ews Devin kogan saying that Gosling
steals the show Mike Ryan of uprox was
equally enthusiastic calling Gosling a
delight as can there's also overwhelming
praise for Greta Gerwig the captain of
the Barbie ship Empire's Beth Webb wrote
Greta goig delivers a new kind of
ambitious and glittery entertaining
Blockbuster that boasts two definitive
performances from actors already in
their stride life after Barbie will
simply never be the same again
foreign
[Music]